le voy a pedir a hpt que me haga ganar
la mayor cantidad de dinero posible en
el menor tiempo posible haciendo trading
Bueno pues ya preparado por aquí la
estrategia entonces lo que voy a hacer
es lo siguiente y es algo muy simple ya
simplemente pedirle que me prepare un
painscript para trading digo Bueno pues
en cuestión de segundos tenemos esto y
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
simplemente copiar esto
básicamente es una página web que nos
permite poder ver los gráficos
básicamente Pues esta estrategia
etcétera etcétera Este vídeo lo más
interesante posible
esta estrategia y Vamos a ingresar
durante 7 días para poder ver cuánto
dinero consigo ganar ya estamos había
jueves y ya llevo una semana utilizando
este Bot yo os lo voy a enseñar y lo que
tenemos que hacer es seleccionar todo lo
que queremos sumar en este caso sumar
todas las ganancias y pérdidas para ver
resultado final así que hago esto y me
parece que en total hemos ganado 4,05
dólares en 7 días esto pues es poco
dinero pero tenemos que calcular como
que ha ganado 4 dólares
realmente alta simplemente creo que
consigo ganar dinero con este Bot porque
he tenido suerte y porque todo el
mercado ha ido